foreign
thing I'd like to do is encourage people
who have a little bit of doubt if you
got a lot of bit of doubt it might not
work a little bit of doubt I think we
can get past that hurdle
I don't consider myself to be smart or
intelligent or do better anything better
than anybody else and I was able through
just
a little bit of perseverance to sort of
get there I I believe that if I can do
it and I was dumb I got nothing but
these you know in school and stuff like
that if I can do it I just I just think
there are so many people up there and
what I do at times it's frustrating to
me I'm up on stage sometimes at comic
conventions I don't even talk about
comic books but I I go I'm going to talk
to you as your dad is your uncle and I'm
going to tell you why I think you should
try this and I think we've spoken about
some of those on your show in these two
parts right just just try it and if it
doesn't work it's like cutting your hair
to grow back you can always go back to
the system wherever you're at you can
always go back there's no there's no
harm there's no
dishonesty and trying and failing that's
okay right the person who never tries I
think sort of has more regret
so I talked to him I stand on one side
of the stage and I go you know come on
man I I just try try it once I think
everybody in honesty Tim should to try
to be an entrepreneur once in their life
and then I walk to the other stage
and I go now I'm going to talk to you is
Todd the CEO I hope you don't do it I
hope you sow those doubts and you never
do it and you know why because that
means I will never have to compete with
you and you may be smarter and better
and more well equipped and I'll never
have to play the game against you so
make my life easy and don't compete but
I'm telling you the dad side of me take
me down man because because the 25 year
old Todd I'm telling you I just know
would have would have listened to me the
60 year old man and would have said dude
I will gut you oh I try like I would
never have let an old man on that stage
go I hope you don't do it because you're
not good enough like I would have I
would have gone and said oh yeah I've
made it my personal mission so even if
even if I can just gin up
a couple of people to just go come on
man come on man you can do it but if you
keep coming up with reasons why you're
not built for entrepreneurship
you have to think a little bit
delusional at times to the point where
you think you're better than you are
that's okay that's okay confidence is
half the battle and now we got to figure
out whether you got the skill sets which
is the other half but some of the skill
can come along the way because
confidence
and determination can take you pretty
far until you learn those skills so just
go go go that's all I've got